welcome back to another episode of
matrix math here on code Tech and
tutorials this time we're going to show
you how to solve linear systems by the
substitution method and if you're not
sure what the linear system is I
recommend just going and looking at the
last video kind of explains how to set
them all up what they look like so what
you need to know about substitution
method is it is the human way of solving
these problems computers don't like this
method well we'll get into that a little
more but basically this requires some
creative problem solving and computers
aren't exactly good at creative problem
solving so in the next episode I'll talk
about another method where you can kind
of program this for a computer and it's
called Gaussian elimination we're just
going to set up a little equation and
and dive right into it so we're going to
start out with this system of equations
we'll do an X Y Z so first equation is X
plus 2y that's a 2 plus Z equals 3 and
then the second equation is 2x plus 3y
minus Z equals negative 6 and we have a
3x minus 2y minus 4z and that one it's
going to equal negative 2 so what we can
do with these system equations is we can
start solving for x y and z and then
going through and back substituting in
what the results we get
so by that by doing that we should be
able to come up with some sort of
solution now it's possible that there's
no solution it's possible that there are
infinite solutions and it's possible
that there is a nice clean solution so
we're going to take a look at that we'll
start with the first equation this one
here so on this equation we're going to
put X off by itself so we will subtract
X from both both sides we'll end up with
a negative x equals and let's see we're
also going to subtract 3 from both sides
well this X cancels out with it's
negative so we're going to go off right
under that Y and then plus the Z and
then negative
three and then we want to get this
negative off of this side so we're gonna
just reverse it so we'll just say I
don't know scribbled out plain old X is
going to now equal well the negative of
all this this all times negative one so
what we get there is a negative 2y minus
Z plus three and that's pretty much as
far as we can simplify it X is going to
equal that whole chunk of stuff okay
very good so now we want to go to the
next equation and attempt to solve for y
but this time why we're doing this we
can figure out what we learned about X
and just substitute this whole little
thing in and for that for that X so it's
going to reset up basically to have
let's see here 2x we're done with this
one for the moment so I'm going to put a
line I'm looking at this one now so
we're looking at 2x but instead of that
X I'm some but instead of the X we're
going to substitute in the answer we got
here so it's gonna be + or I will go
ahead and multiply it through with this
- just to do it save a little bit of
steps so what we're looking at here is
just let's see 2 multiplied by negative
2 y is going to be negative 4y and then
2 times negative Z is just going to be
negative 2z and then we just have this 3
of course 2 times 3 6 so just a positive
6 there and then we go on with the
equation we have a 3y and another
negative is this negative 2 or negative
see it's it's negative see okay just
making sure
Z's and 2's are confusing all right so
this 3y we actually want to be
here so we're going to subtract 3y from
both sides and add 6 to both sides so
let's go ahead and arithmetic that out
how we can hear but also we're going to
end up dividing by negative 3 to turn
the side into just a plane negative 3
and it's going to look a little
confusing maybe we don't go ahead and do
all the Y thing yet let's just solve
this with the new X in place and put all
the like terms together I think that'll
be a little better here for just a quick
solve so I because this will basically
be the first iteration as we go through
these and the second iteration we'll
figure out what Y is so I hope that
makes sense but let's go ahead ok so
this positive 3y is gonna stay positive
3y then in that case and subtract to see
that's a Z and then I guess I want to
put a little line through it just to
make it clear there now a better Z
hopefully and not to 7 equals negative 6
so when we have this whole system of
equations we're going to put we're gonna
just combine some things together here
see we go to Y we got a Y it looks like
it's going to be a negative Y so we got
negative Y because negative 4 and
positive 3 is just negative 1 then we
got a Z here and a Z here we got a
negative 2z and a negative z that's
going to be a negative 3z overall and
we've got this 6 here that's just
chilling so we got 8 plus 6 and looks
like that's all we've got at the moment
and that's kind of course equal negative
6
okay and I guess we could put this
negative this six over to one side just
to combine it so we're going to end up
with the same thing basically except
negative twelve on one side and that
makes a lot of sense because it saves us
a little room equals negative twelve so
now we've got that second one so we got
the first X iteration which is x equals
this we've got the second in a root the
first to the right or the second
iteration of the Y with that X put in
here and we want to do the same thing
with Z so we're looking at this equation
in this equation and we'll do one more
do we have space I'm not sure we'll try
we'll try I'll see how much I can
simplify it down let's see how do we
want to do this I have the third
equation and we're gonna substitute in
the X once again and it's going to look
like well maybe I'll have a room right
over here to do that real quick let me
grab this eraser it's not a big eraser
it's a small eraser okay let's let's
just do it this way then and and maybe
we'll have room for the third one over
here so we got 3x the 3x is going to
turn into well the X is going to turn
into this whole setup that we already
solved so it's going to be negative six
why why - all right which turns into a
positive here because let's see three
times now it's going to be it's gonna be
negative still okay three times Z now is
Z right you know is going to be of
course or three times negative Z is
going to be negative three is Z and then
three times three is going to be nine so
plus nine and then we just keep on with
the rest of able to go to negative two y
then we got a negative for Z and all
that's going to equal negative two so we
basically just keep solving this as much
as we can let's put the Y's together if
we get negative 8y and put the Z's
together we get negative seven see
that's a confusing one negative seven Z
and we put
like terms together it looks like we can
just subtract this on the other side and
we will end up with negative 11 so we
got negative 8y minus 7 Z equals
negative 11 and that appears to be right
for this first iteration I mean go ahead
and copy this go to our new layer I'm
gonna hide my old one to paste that in
and we'll move this over so now we're on
these three equations where we now solve
for y and when we solve for y we're
gonna discover a new equation to throw
in for Y and we can substitute that into
back into this first equation and we can
also sub it in for this last equation
and we'll be on our second iteration so
let's go ahead and work on this middle
one and I'll do it
up here in this top right area so let's
get negative Y off by itself by turning
it into a positive Y and flopping it to
the other side of the equal sign here
and the same with this 12 let's put it
on the other side by adding it to both
sides so what we're gonna end up with is
y equals negative 3z plus 12 and now we
have y y all by itself and set up to a
whole thing so we can go let's see this
is here and we can take this equation
now and we'll say okay well now since we
have an update at Z we can our an
updated Y we can get rid of this Y and
by subbing it in so it's going to be X
now equals let's see this whole quick oh
why is this whole equation so it'll be 2
times all of this so it's x is going to
equal negative 6z and then let's see the
2 times 12 is going to be 24 plus 24 and
then the rest of here of course negative
2 or negative Z I'm sorry and a positive
3 so that's ultimately going to equal us
it's put the Z's together at negative 7
Z plus let's see 24 + 3 is 27 plus 27 so
now we simplified our X a little more
all the way down to XE
fools negative 7 Z plus 27
let's see I guess I didn't necessarily
have to substitute it into this X yet so
I'm doing this in a little different
order than other people might do it but
let's go ahead and go to this third
equation and figure out what it is and
so we have a value to put in for the Y
now so it's a negative 8 in front of
that Y so it's gonna be negative 8 times
let's see yeah well let's just do it ok
so it's gonna be this Y is going to be
this entire thing so it's gonna be
negative 8 times negative 3 Z and that
turns out to be a positive 24 Z
that's a Z okay and then we have
negative 8 times this 12 and of course
that is going to be what some large
number having trouble Matthew off the
top of my head see it's at least 80 plus
12 so it's gonna be 92 but it's a
negative because there's one negative so
it's negative of 92 and that's all for
that negative 8 and then it was what
minus 7 Z equals negative 11 so we can
combine these up the like terms here and
we get let's just make sure this works
we hit a 24 Z and a negative 7 Z so we
basically subtract 7 z off of that and
we end up with a 17 Z and we're gonna
add 92 to this other side so it's
basically they're going to be 17 Z
equals let's see what is what is 92 okay
we're at negative 11 we add 92 so
basically the number we're going to end
up with is the positive of this 92 minus
11 and that is going to be
I can't thank 81-81 so we ended with 17
Z equals 81 so that's that's a pretty
good second iteration there and we can
now move on to the third iteration where
we solve for Z and actually we've got it
done pretty much already all we got to
do is just uh Z is going to equal 18
divided by 17 and that might be
something easy
so this I'll put a little two here for
that being the second iteration now the
third iteration so I think I have room
here we're going to start with this Z
and the that this is easy it's Z equals
81 and we're gonna divide both sides by
17 and now we have Z all by itself and
when we come up with this answer what is
it 17 times 5 I think let me pull up a
calculator real quick here and just do
us quick seven oh wait well 17 times
five and see if that's 81 no that's 85
so that's not quite right did I math
this wrong I might have math this wrong
cuz it's okay let me do this again here
negative 8 times 3 is 24
negative 8 times 12 I think if this 8
times 12
I might might have done this wrong is 96
so there was been an air of an error
there if you caught that ahead of time
kudos to you so this is a 96
I just math that were a little wrong my
bad
so that would basically make this final
number over here actually 5 higher so
it's an 85 God you can't tell that's a 5
so I'm gonna do some hyper deleting here
and just fix this up real quick so that
we don't look like a complete noob so
this being a 96 yeah that's a 6 geez
what an ugly 6 96 deal with it alright
and that's gonna be 85 so now we get 85
divided by 17 and we just can't win here
with the over writing we're gonna have
to use the the tools of the trade
so what this ends up equaling is a
pretty nice even number because 17 will
go into 285 five times and so we end up
with five so Z is equal to five and now
with Z equal to just a plain number we
can backfill it into the rest so I'm
going to put an FA here for a final
answer and we now know that Z is equal
to five so we can fill this back in to
the old ones which we have on the
iteration two here so I'm going to look
at the let's look at the Y now let's
look at the X it doesn't matter what
order we go I'll reverse order Y it is
since we're on the third one here so Y
is equal to negative three Z so we just
basically put in a five for the Z so
it's going to be minus 15 plus 12
because this will be a 5 right
so negative 3 times 5 is negative 15 and
then plus 12 so we're gonna come out
with the total result here of a negative
3 and we can now say and our final
answer that Y is equal to negative 3
and here we also want to go ahead and do
the X and where's our X right here
negative 7 Z so negative 7 times 5 we
all know very well is 35 so it's going
to be negative 35 look at that I'm good
at 3 negative 35 here in our case
because it's negative 7 times 5 and then
we're gonna add 27 to that and we end up
with the difference between 35 and 27
which we all know very well is but what
because X is supposed to be 4 in our
final answer here so why am I getting 8
and not 4 so let's back up the first one
I ended up with x equals let's see
negative 2y I might have dropped I might
have accidentally dropped this negative
negative 2y so I think this should have
been positive is what we're looking at
here right here because this and I
didn't see this negative probably
negative negative 2 times the y
it's going to make this six positive so
it's going to be positive six right
there and that comes up with a very
different answer here but we'll see if
it equals four like we intended so now
when we swap in that five for Z we get
five times five is 25 Oh wrong tool so
we get 25 minus 21 and that does equal
four so now we have X is four and that
is the right answer for that system of
equations so hopefully we're able to
follow that I feel like I maybe got a
little bit messy but that is essentially
how you solve by substitution and as you
as you can see we basically kind of
methodically go through it and replace
an update as we go through and it's it's
a way for humans to solve these
equations computers have trouble with it
I bet there I feel like I feel like
there's a way to do it I bet a computer
could do it because one thing that's
unique about this method is these XY and
z variables starting from the very
beginning when they're in matrix form
they never actually change so whatever's
holding them can kind of be permanently
retro actively updated but it's still
going to be a bit confusing all right so
be sure to tune in for the next video
when we talk about Gaussian elimination
so peace out guys